well I think um really watershed moment
that really isn't a lot to me mmm the
last I guess three years was that I took
philosophy of religion with Professor
Proudfoot my sophomore year and became
very close with him and you know I I
guess he had responded to my writing and
I worked with him a lot i really i
really liked him a lot and he at the end
of the year when I was scrambling to
find something to do with my with my
summer and try to figure out what I
wanted to do you know in July and August
happened to email me that a former
student is was writing a book called
divine rebels about social justice
workers who use religion as a
justification for the actions that
they've taken and whether they have
civil unrest or you know there are a lot
of cases about it then school of the
americas was a chapter and Quaker
pacifists and the war in Vietnam and so
this was kind of the overall topic and
he he told me that she needed a student
editor and to look over our work and
that he thought that I would be good for
the position so I wrote her an email we
immediately hit it off and we she sent
me the entirety of her book which I like
line edited over the summer was this
crazy experience and I hadn't had done
this kind of editing since like high
school with like like high school
newspaper but I not only learned a
tremendous amount and actually a lot of
the stuff that I had read in a
particular chapter of hers Dena Guster
is the author of the book led me to a
lot of the research that I did this year
about environmental justice work and
particular people that I wanted to look
at his case studies and so it was really
a seminal text for me in that regard but
it also was this moment when I thought
okay I figure out how how I can take
religious studies theory
some of the anthropological studies that
we have like that I've read and apply it
to something practically like writing a
book and the process that that actually
goes through and the fact that professor
professor Brad foot was willing to go
out on a limb with this writer and offer
me up as as potential editor was really
meant the world to me and Dina and I are
very close to and we still work together
sometimes she works at democracy now
which is a radio station in midtown and
she showed me the offices and she's been
sort of a good mentor to me and so this
very you know happy it just happened to
get this email and if I hadn't had
something you know if I hadn't been
looking for something then I would have
missed out on this important piece of my
life and it really felt like I got kind
of what what the perspective is and the
philosophy is of this department in that
book and it was all of my personal
experience with doing advocacy work and
that kind of thing which like I wasn't
really sure how to how to take that to a
more academic place suddenly made sense
in context of what I had learned in my
classes so it was was a really great
experience I felt really great
afterwards to was like I had it in a
book awesome that's so cool